[Music]
it's great to be back here again
that's the key you know I'm grateful
that's why I named my new album grateful
because I'm grateful for these
opportunities and I know you knew you
know you are your great collaborations
you choose the other performers the
other artists that you work with very
well I mean obviously who are some
people out there that you'd like to
collaborate with that you haven't yet
man well this album that's coming out
grateful I'm pulling off all the people
that I haven't had a chance to
collaborate with on this album you're
saying you see I dropped on the one that
went number one on the Billboard Hot 100
with Justin Bieber yeah me little Wayne
and quello and chance the rapper then I
did my first single with Beyonce and
jay-z so I pulled off my checklist with
Beyonce went number one true I pulled
off my checklist with Justin Bieber
where do you go for me well I'm working
with Rihanna on my album everyone to
work with she's on my album you're
saying how does it come about you just
protocol I mean like does everybody want
to work with you check out I mean you
know it's about being great you're
saying and when you're great and then
when they get to know you and you make
great music and the Energy's right in
the vibes right that's a bonus I'm
saying is at the end of the day is I'm
gonna always make great music we the
best I'd like to see you is one of the
American Idol judges coming up on the on
that on ABC reincarnation of the show
would you what do you think about that
let me tell you something you're a
genius
I love I'm not gonna argue a genius
matter of fact let's make that happen
ASAP hey
you